[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we all
[Music]
can be thrown away
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
as
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like a 6am
[Music]
we'll walk into the sunrise
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
yeah
baby welcome to the world famous
stuttering john podcast
i'm at my mom's house today after a very
grueling trip to dc
uh
i'll tell you all about it
it's not pretty
let's just say
it's just not pretty it's not fun it's
not funny it's not pretty
scary
in true danish fashion i'm enjoying
coffee
because
i'm beat
anyway pacquiaono
is here
joni heisenberg don winslow has a very
interesting background he was a private
investigator at safari guide in kenyan a
theater director and oxford all in
addition to being a fabulous writer
and political activist and filmmaker he
makes just like the minus touch
brothers do and the lincoln project don
winslow does a lot of those films as
well he's done a great job
josh shermer shorty one is here
uh shorty one john i was wondering if
you have thought about having comebacks
in case people like
marjorie trail of green decide to fight
back when you approach them in
dc um
i
i wouldn't need it i had so many
questions for her
never ran into her
uh well i'll tell you all about it
tony pence refused to get into the
secret service car of january 6th i am
not getting in that car i'm sure it
crossed his mind he may not be seen or
heard from again if he did
a mod can you do me a favor and grab my
computer bag that great bag
or at least the papers inside it please
sweetheart
thank you
joanie
republicans have already come up with a
moniker to discredit the dhs
establishment of disinformation
governance board calling at the
orwellian ministry of truth okay
um
oh my god uh joanie love george
takai's recently you know donald i've
also known
i've also been known to be a very
dangerous fruit
all righty george takai hey now
hi mom say hi to everybody
hi
how you doing school
so
uh the squeegee lion of judea
uh joni heisenberg mark meadows and sean
had to exchange more than a text message
between election day 2020 president
biden's inauguration
carl jacobson my danish brethren to
squeegee your new member thank you
thank you very much stage dog is here
cb is here john decker jill carter
um
john
causey uh
okay john well i'm gonna tell you all
about dc in fact i don't have a guest
coming on
until like 45 minutes because that's how
much i have to tell and i'm gonna play
you what i got
but i'm going to tell you what happened
first
john from las vegas and bezler hi
everyone hope huge fan of don winslow
heard he would be on
made the leap to join youtube in here to
check out john well thank you mr bezel
and let me tell you something
i've been working on booking don winslow
and he'll tell you
for about five months he was here once
but for five months
we've been going back and forth because
he want to wait until his new book city
on fire look at this piece of hair don't
get
it looks like i have something on my lip
ah whatever
um
marcia genulis
is here uh admiral sulu how did your
audio visual crew in dc work out
um
how did they work out
um
let me just say uh
not good
thank you ma i could hear me my i can
oh could you
could you go downstairs maybe watch or
something or upset i don't have to hear
you yeah all right um
uh facebook people during this broadcast
you can support my page by sending stars
a digital gift that helps me earn money
carlene martin from iowa sherry p
i can still hear myself mom
please go upstairs to downstairs
sweetheart please
mexicali maggie a william zavallo
love you
flores richie andrea mccready
nikki b johnny mars max keller maggie jm
vandy
uh john death nikki be my moderator in
chief bicycle mike 42 martha salinas
nikki b knows the story already nancy
cox johnny mars
alien connie heather
um shorty one nancy cox purple snake in
the grass
um john jeff jacqueline mazakin chapman
trina miner uh
uh benny loco i she knows the deal too i
talked to talk to my moderator uh uh
betty loco about the first night of
incompetency
but there's a second day benny loco
and it only gets more unbelievable and
worse
uh thanks for that super chat i love you
uh christina garcia is here
chess flexer
robin brazil
robert myers
uh david patterson from vancouver island
canada
the cynthia rice um
katrina alton galepsy
um
liz gallo
bonnie evans
um
harmon sullivan
uh
nancy cox i believe i said with the
badge regina gavin from indiana we're
picking up new people all the time lacey
carter
uh
[Music]
uh righty freedom speech and you hello
to you as well
uh david saxon paula bradley line of
judea train of mine juan hernandez
um
darius
parker uh type me
how are you
yeah hit that hit that thumbs up
jeanette de harjen from windsor ontario
canada russell johnson still on that
island love to hear it there my friend
um
d mccann
uh
uh let's see uh let's see tim grayson
uh oh thank you yes i'm hero of the
stupid thank you very much paula bradley
you know you should really research how
that name came about first it's actually
not an insult um if i could represent
the blue collar people of the world
that's fine with me i'd rather i'd
rather do that than represent the
wealthy
and the white collar uh
people kenneth otto not to say there's
anything wrong with with them either but
you know
uh i'm i'm from a blue collar family so
nancy cox emergency
uh a remedial truth buys to 21. um
yvonne watkin uh
chet pants
from twitch
um
stuttering george carlin okay juan
hernandez
uh
uh paula bradley
laura ipsum with the badge
um captain turp you're gonna want to
hear this story if you just hear the
story
it might be worth the amount of money i
spent to go to dc
lynette
kuwa
um
okay
that's right benny loco it's super chat
saturday thank you
ty herzin back and believe me i could
use to make some of this cash i shelled
out jackie hobson
uh
oh the trolls are here okay sean wallace
uh uh let's see
robin masters hope that was worth the
two bucks patty free burn
uh
uh
uh
[Music]
let's see
uh anita blake
dominic with tomorrow junior paula
bradley
uh
uh let's see patty freeburn
uh okay
lauren ipsum
thank you for the five bucks
all right
so
you know i hop you know
i paid a friend
to write you know some questions with me
um
you know
um and then i paid for the hotel i paid
for the amtrak
uh
the amtrak
was um
uh
370 i think for a round-trip amtrak
370.
i paid for the hotel which i thought was
370. it turns out i look at my uh bank
account today was 467.
for one night
one night 467. i called the hotel
okay the guy behind the counter you know
he kind of liked me his name is
you know you know his name is benny he's
like
i go dude
you know you said it was gonna be like
360. what the oh yeah there's a city
chart city charge
yeah that's 30 bucks
what and then this hotel tax and this in
it
the [ __ ]
okay
then the ubers to get to the hotel it's
and then the ubers to get to the
to get to the amtrak from granola's
place the money's just adding up but i
don't care i'm on a mission i'm a man on
a mission
so
i go
and
um
now let me digress
because
i'm ahead of myself here
i put an ad on craigslist
looking for a crew called doug goodstein
he couldn't do it
talk to my nephew he didn't have a
microphone
now i know
just from doing these
for the stern show and the tonight show
i either need a lavalier
which is the microphone for those who
are not in the know
um
that it goes on your lapel
or a microphone
on the stern show i used to have two
mics one for k rock one for e
that's right
two mics and we would tape them together
for the tonight show i would have a
microphone as well to do the
corresponding pieces
so
i look at all the people that respond to
the craigslist ad because goodsteam
can't do it my nephew doesn't have a
microphone
i'm calling everybody i know
can't seem to find anybody
and
i'm like okay
what now
so you know so i go to craigslist and so
i go down a list and i see this one guy
because i put i'm stuttering john if you
know because i'm looking for someone
who's familiar with the kamikaze gorilla
interviews that i've done in the past
because right there do kamikaze gorilla
interviews so
the good news
uh
i find
this guy john i'm a big fan of yours and
you know i'm familiar with your work i
go perfect he knows
he knows the you know
of how it works
okay
okay
so after i do my show
on thursday with the great uh
congressman from illinois sean caston
and of course
the resident genius house sparks
i
then
start to get into my suit because i know
i'm going to the capitol hill club
why because the capitol hill club
is where all the republicans hang out
and
eat and drink
so i call
i call the cameraman
and i say
you know
could you meet me there
uh how long is going to take you to get
there because everyone travels by train
in dc
he goes uh take me 30 minutes i go
bingo i'll meet you in 30 minutes
so i go there in 30 minutes
waiting outside the capitol hill club
oh
plenty of congressmen are walking in
you know what the problem is
i don't have a cameraman
kind of man hasn't shown yet
an hour and a half later
i'm calling the cameraman texting him
where are you
he starts texting me does this mic work
he sends me a desk mic
uh literally
like
a uh
a sennheiser you know uh you know look
you know a picture
uh would this work
uh and i said
no i need a i need an intel microphone
then he texts me again how about this
i'm going oh my god i go yeah that'll
work okay
so then he's an hour goes by he's not
there i say
where are you
i forgot the adapter or i don't have the
adapter for the microphone to go to the
camera i have to pick it up
okay
it starts getting dark i'm starting to
get cold because i have the suit and
just and just the collared shirt
and i'm starting to get cold i see the
congressman coming in and out because
they always have this uh
gold uh round
uh badge on that lapel that's the only
way that i know
um so
i go okay
i'm going to uh
i'm going to freak out here
so that i so i text the guy and i don't
want to say his name because he's a nice
guy
and i say
you know where are you he goes okay i'm
you know i'll be there
i'll be there soon
he says i'll be there in 15 minutes
that's what he said
15 minutes go by
no cameraman
30 minutes go by
i said that's it
i'm done
i said
i'm gonna go i go down to the train
text him
just forget it
all right
you know i'm leaving are you sure i
could be there in five minutes
yeah i went lol yeah that's what you
said an hour and a half ago
so i left
now i only needed for what two hours i
was giving 150 bucks 150 bucks one guy
for two hours
that's it
75 bucks an hour
okay
why didn't i use my phone because to
hold the questions and the phone did you
know it would just be too awkward and it
doesn't look professional the whole
thing is i want to look
like i'm from nudes max which is what i
used nudes max
thank you house sparks
for giving me that lovely little
uh tidbit so
nudes max
you know
nudes max if they can't hear me with the
d that's their problem right
so
i go home
go back to the hotel
i hang out at the bar
and i start calling every other person
on craigslist that answered that ad
every single one of them
and i said
can you come on
you know can you do it tomorrow i'm
going to dc
tomorrow uh can you come
hold on i want to just email you know
you know you know our first guest today
so i said you know uh
i didn't know his email oh yeah there he
is
uh
i said you know uh can you come
and he goes uh
you know and
and they're all not getting back to me
so i'm like i don't know what to do i
don't know
so i'm now i'm stuck
i text
the camera guy that i already had now
you're gonna say john why would you do
that
you already know the guy is
irresponsible but
i didn't have a choice
i'm stuck paying 450 60 dollars
you know for a hotel room 400 almost 400
for the amtrak
the air flight here
you know
like you know it's like
come on
the ubers the freaking cabs everything
so i go okay
i go look i'll tell you what
be at the capitol tomorrow at 10 o'clock
bring a camera
bring a microphone handheld
and be prepared
let's do this and we'll do
capital and we'll do the capitol hill
club
now
the next things i'm going to tell you
you're going to find unbelievable
but it's sad but true
so first i'm waiting waiting waiting 10
30 11 o'clock i'm like where are you
oh uh i'm right in front i go okay well
um
turns out he's in the front like i'm in
the back because they come out in the
back so i go no no it's in the back so
okay that's not i'm not i'm not blaming
that on him so he comes
and he comes with he comes with a camera
stand
i'm like
dude
i don't need a camera stand this is me a
two shot so now i have to show him
the classic stuttering john interviews
on youtube
so he could see the two shot that i need
so he had so he had no idea what the two
shot is he brings a camera still like
you're gonna be
shooting a film here
so
i'm like okay i go dude i don't need the
camera stand
so he begins to shoot like i'm gonna do
like an opening you know hey this is
stuttering john i'm at the capitol he
begins to shoot
all right can we try that again i got
some problem here i go what
he goes
my battery died
i go your battery died
he goes yeah
i go
well you must have another battery right
no i don't i'm like what
you brought one battery
for a camera
now granted
when i would do shoots with the tonight
show they would have four batteries
when i did the shoots with the
stern show
they would have two or three batteries
no cameraman would only bring one
battery
so he goes
well i'll tell you what
i got my girl coming she's bringing the
battery
i go
all right
so we wait 20 minutes
in the meantime i hear
a teacher you know because they're
bringing these like tours of all these
students
i hear a teacher go
uh um
so kids now you'll notice there's no
flag over where the house
meets and there's no flag over where the
senate meets the reason for that is
because congress is not in session
i go
she's got to be wrong
she better be wrong so i look up on my
phone
and it says congress is in session today
on
on the house of representative on their
on their schedule site it says
congress is in session
but
she says that i go nah she's got to be
wrong here i have it on my phone
on the calendar on the count of the
teabags it says it was in session
i swear in my life i checked this before
i left i checked it
and i checked it again and i checked it
when i was in front of the capitol
so luckily a congressman does show up
unfortunately for me or maybe
fortunately i'll tell you why
it's a democrat
i can't remember his name offhand i
posted a picture with him
really nice guy he's a congressman from
california i think mark takano
and his assistant atlanta really nice
person i'll play you some video to show
you the next debacle
this
is a comedy
a comedy of errors
a comedy of errors
okay
so
i said
i don't get it it says on the calendar
here
that
congress is in session is it she goes
no no they canceled it like a day ago
but two days ago i go what
she goes yeah i think it's because uh
and she said something i didn't
understand yeah there was some like
probes or something something yeah i
could you gotta be kidding me again
i come all this way this time i take a
four hour train ride on the amtrak
and an hour car ride to new york
so total like five hours to get here and
now they're not in session again
okay
now
the cameraman's girl shows up with a
battery
great right
no
no
because guess what happens
the battery that she buys
is the wrong size
it's the wrong battery
baby yoda thanks for the two
bucks she brings the wrong
battery
so i go
i go you got to be kidding me i go you
really have to be kidding me you told me
you knew what you were doing you told me
you've done this before you told me you
were a fan in europe and
and you're familiar with my interviews
and you bring a camera with dead battery
and then they go and buy
for another one uh
uh so then here it is
so here it is so there i am i go okay
we're just gonna shoot on cell phones
all right
so let's go to the capitol hill club
now keep in mind
the guy's a nice guy i have no problem
with them except
that he misled me
you know but i can't get you know i
can't start screaming at him because
this is all i got now
and his girl is super sweet
so we drive
in her car to the capitol hill club
which is really literally like
right around the block
so we start shooting on a cell phone
so i asked him can you both shoot on
your cell phones in case we have a
problem we have backup
so they both shoot on the cell phone
the cameraman's cell phone
he's trying to upload it to me goes
i don't get it
i go you don't get what
he goes um
my audio doesn't work on my cell phone
i'm like you gotta be kidding me
he goes man i'm i'm really mad i go yeah
as mad as you are i'm 10 times as mad
so then
so now i'm just stuck with his girl
with her phone
because then he tries to upload it to me
because i can only send it in
in two files so it'll be edit it'll be
two clips
i go you have got to be kidding me
you've got to be kidding me
so
so we start doing some interviews
i think like two or three congressmen
show up i ask him some questions
now keep in mind the audio sucks you
could barely hear me you could barely
hear them
and
when i show you
what she's shooting and how she's doing
it
you are not going to believe
that this
this is what happened
so
i'm not having my cell phone so when you
hold up a cell phone and you take video
she holds it up
and then
flips it to the side while doing well
i'm doing the interview
so you have me like this and then like
this
i am like
now i don't realize that that's what's
going on until i look at one of them and
i don't
after i interview mario van peebles
i realize
she's flipping back and forth
and i'm in shock
i cannot believe it
so this pretty much is garbage
what i'm gonna show you is garbage
now i had promised all my patreon and
youtube members oh i'll you know i'll
get it to you as soon as i get some when
i saw the quality of this
man
it wasn't worth it maybe one of you guys
could tell me who these congressmen are
because i don't even know their names
no marjorie trailer green
no lauren beauberg
no matt gates
no mitch mcconnell
and we had great questions
from marjory trailer green
oh this
is schindler's list your favorite comedy
uh are you gonna be going on dancing
with the stars with your first dance be
the goose step
uh
i mean just you know you got fine 2500
for not wearing a mask on the house
floor if anyone should be wearing a mask
shouldn't it be you
uh
just you know a whole bunch a whole
bunch of questions
but no
you know and a whole bunch of questions
for all these people
so
i digress
and i'm going to just show you a little
bit and i'm going to show you so what i
do now is i have this audio that's awful
i have the video that's
awful um
you know i spent
well over a grand probably closer to
1500 on everything
all for naught
now look
i'm not
no look i know it sounds like i'm
whining here i'm mad for you guys
because i know that you wanted me to get
some good people and get some good
interviews i know it
and and that's what i did i had my
brother's suit which i know everyone
commented on twitter john
man you look horrible in a suit i go i
know
i hate wearing a suit i've hated wearing
a suit since my communion
i don't like
suits i look like crap in suits
so by the way that picture of me in a
suit i have a sweatshirt underneath the
suit because it's it's cold in dc
so i got a sweatshirt
and then the then the college shirt then
the tie
and the jacket
so when it's sunny i'm sweating my ass
off and when it's when it's windy i'm
freezing
i'm surprised i haven't caught a cold or
covered or
something so i look like crap i know it
i know this i know this video stinks
but i'll show it to you
so
here i'll bring on tony martinez here as
i do this
tony martinez tony michaels this is how
upset i am i can't even speak
oh boy
all right
so i'm just gonna show you
what i mean
by by the flips okay
so
let me just show you this okay
tony michaels how are you good how are
you sir gabe sanchez how are you good
thanks for having us gabe
co-host what's the show guys
the tony michael's podcast we are live
every single weekday noon eastern 11
central on youtube twitter and twitch
and we broadcast from the midas touch
facebook page as well
two hours every single weekday monday
through friday and gabriel gabriel i'm
surprised he got his microphone working
we give him a lot of [ __ ]
over on our show he he
he's not as fast on the microphone
button is he well i like to you know
like i said i like to be cordial i keep
myself muted in the green room yeah tony
brings me into the show i you know
sometimes forget to bring it off the
music right right all right
well i've heard that you had you know
gabe has technical difficulties i heard
you had a little bit about it i hired a
camera guy
for 150 a day like two hours or three
hours a day or whatever you know i put
eight hours but i knew i wasn't gonna do
eight hours but you know anyway
and the guy
is unprepared
he only comes with one battery that
doesn't work
then his girl brings another battery
wrong battery
and then his cell phone doesn't work the
audio everything so then his girls got
to shoot it now i'm going to show you
how his girl
is shooting now i don't blame her she's
not a you know she's not qualified you
know she's not you know she's just
trying to help because she's a
sweetheart
so here i'm gonna just play you this so
you can see how she's this is me talking
to a congressman's assistant okay
so check this out this is how she's
shooting it
uh
she's like 80 feet away from me
all right so now she's
okay now here we go with the zoom and
then look
now i'm sideways
now i'm sideways people
i am sideways
okay
all right and you you you paid this guy
to do this or rather you paid the guy
and then the girlfriend did it
uh uh hold on let me get
let me just get it
okay so now i'm sideways
this is this is from the dc trip right
yes this is this is this is uh
this is on friday who who are you
talking to there and this that is
her name is lana she's an assistant
assistant you know uh
for a congressman i see i see i see hey
now i'm gonna play you mario
van peebles now okay and i'll tell you
guys i'm at the capitol hill club
the capitol hill club is it says on the
door
republican hangout whatever that's not
the exact you know
republicans only know democrats
right the the she-man woman haters club
is it yes yes yes
now i'm gonna show you how she shoots my
interview with mario van peebles now
my first question because when mario van
peels
is walking in i don't even know who he
is but thankfully
these guys do
so i go and mario looks like he wants to
be interviewed because he keeps looking
at us and looking at us like please
interview me
please interview me and i go no no no
and and then i didn't know
so now i'm gonna wait till he leaves
okay now this is how that was shot
okay now first this is on the same cell
phone are they shooting it on the same
cell phone
yes yes
and now i'm going to ask him
like
mario
you're a person of
all color why are you
at
you know
a republican place like i don't get it
you know right i mean
here they are
suppressing the votes from
people of color and you're here with
them
okay
now i'm gonna show you
okay how she shoots mario been people
this is when i almost
lose it okay
so here we go
this is this is so
here we go
do you see it
oh yeah okay here we go
wow look at this
look at this
i'm sideways
i am sideways john john my suggestion is
what you should have done is fired your
camera guy and just handed your phone to
like a you know just like a teenager
they would have they would have
definitely been able to
dip it in this feels like the day was
just riddled with murphy's law like
everything it's the keystone cops
look
i didn't look i've done
the stern show the tonight show you know
with like professional camera crews
you know these people claim to be
professional they claim yes they are
they are
they are well i mean
it's questionable it is questionable
right now all right
okay so now
now i'm like what am i going to do
so i tell the cameraman he goes i could
fix it
i got some tools i mean it's literally
like just a hammer like a hammer i mean
i can edit it i can fix it i can i can
make the audio better i could you know i
could change all this i could fix it so
not only are they professional camera
people obviously but they're
professional editors as well is that yes
so
while i'm on the amtrak because now
after the mario van peoples that's the
last one and i go i'm out of here right
so i go you know what go home you know
and now i'm like you know i have a i
have a subway card because i'm not going
to use it
so the girl is kind enough to drive me
to the hotel get my bags and then drive
me to union station so i can get at it
again i have no problem with the you
know you know i'm not you know i didn't
you know like i wasn't going to yell at
him i'm just like okay let's just go i'm
you know i'm done you know
so then i just he says he can fix it
so i'm on the amtrak you know
it's about you know it's a few hours
later i go any chance that you fix this
oh uh you know what you know what you
know i'm at my show i'll do it as soon
as i can he goes but can you ban my me
the money
i go
okay here i go all right
no [ __ ] way
yes and i go you know what i promise i
promised that i'd pay him
so i got to right so i'm like you know
i'm a man of my word unlike this guy
because he keeps on telling me that he's
going to do something he doesn't so i
then mode you know like the 150 bucks
for the three hours or whatever that we
were there and he goes uh
you know and it's because i felt bad his
girlfriend said and and get this
the battery that she brought
you know you know that wasn't the right
size as soon as they opened it out of
the package
the place they bought it from won't take
it back so she can't get a refund
and she spent 80 bucks on this stuff
so now i feel bad you know so now i'm
going to bed why would you why would you
feel bad yeah they made all these
[ __ ]
john there's people in the comments here
that i've watched they said you might
have got punk do you think he got punked
do you think i don't have so i don't
think
because to be punk you have to have some
you know i mean who knows maybe they
were maybe this is just like a big troll
that they put on you wait then it's an
awesome scam god bless you
then it's the best scam that i've ever
you know since since i stole the gary
puppet this is the best scam
you know this is better than me taping
scott the engineer's phone phone down if
this is a scam absolutely because the
the phone the turning the phone at that
right at the right just the right time
is beautiful if that really
if that really was the intention was to
scam you and troll you that well that's
why most beautiful thing in the world
i'll tell you tony
nothing will be funnier than this right
now of me showing you
this kind this is the best part of any
of these interviews
i promise you because the audio is just
the returning of the phone
yes and the other weird thing that i
wanted to tell you before i play these
interviews
at the capitol hill club the capitol
hill police keep on going in it and
having lunch there and i'm going
how the hell are the capitol hill
uh police
going into the right wing
club when it was the right wing
that are responsible for the beatings
that their colleagues had maybe they got
a good chicken strip basket i don't know
[Laughter]
i don't know maybe the chef salad is
decent in there i don't know
give him a smack in that big wide head
of his please
i will i won't holy crap it looks like
he's you know he's he's built to go to
mardi gras you don't got to put that
thing on
sorry anthony but anyway
i digress yeah so i don't know why the
capitol hill police are there but okay
so now
i'll play you
so now this is what i do i call a good
friend of mine from the tonight show who
happened to be an editor you know and
he's a good editor you know like he's
worked edited for the aussie for the
actual professional editor
yeah right right he goes john
you know i'm in the city
i'll you know i'll check it out
and then you know just send it to me and
then i'll say so i get up at 8 30 in the
morning
and
and like i upload it to him
and then i get a text from him this
morning
john this is the shittiest footage i've
ever seen in my life
gabe stuff before that he's like yeah
you're gonna have to redo this yeah he's
like
it's not gonna work
he's like john this is unsavable he goes
yeah he goes just consider it a learning
experience
so i'm like i'm like nah i you know
so uh i go just you know just try and
fix the flips at least you know he goes
i can't fix the audio i go we'll just
fix the flips
so um did he fix the flips did he get
the did he rotate him did he get it i'll
show you what he's this the best a
professional editor could do because
he's like don you don't understand it's
from one frame to another this is like
this is garbage gabe would kill me gabe
would kill me if i sent him anything
like that he would kill me because gabe
does all the editing for ourselves you
know god bless him you know i didn't you
know you know like he's like i'll do it
for you don't pay me he said just do me
a favor
plug this tell your subscribers
um if they can um come to my show so i
mean to his to his podca
podcast platform so everyone please in
this chat
the
it let's see i-t-i-n-e-r-a-n-t
it's
it's an errant jackass the internet
jackass i'll post it in the chats here
so if everyone could please follow this
please go ahead and follow this guy
because you know i mean he did the
lord's work and trying to um
you know
you know i think i think the lord's work
was the camera work really honestly yeah
this i mean it was like it's so bad
it's good right right right like like
like you could you could not it's it's
one of those things where like you
couldn't even try to make it like that
it just just happened right now it just
is
i know hold on i just got to write this
down because it because it won't copy
from like the let's see i t i n
i t i n
e r a n t
all right so there it is
please people
subscribe to my buddy because he did
this now i'll play here
the mario the the audio you really can't
hear
you know
you know so i asked him the first
question how could you be here well
you're a person of color i'm because
this wasn't only about asking like a
funny question it was about asking like
serious questions to these jackaloons
you know what i mean like it wasn't
going to be like you know
you know you know you fought in the
cat's face i wanted to just ask i'd have
questions for him i didn't know that he
was going to be here
uh it's it thank you benny love for two
bucks it's anthony and gabe but it's
okay yeah so here we gave engage
i'm i'm gabe in a game or in a tony mask
at the same time okay so let me see if i
could let me uh let me i said now i got
to keep on stop sharing it because
because i can't go back for some reason
so hold on
all right uh oh you know i maybe have to
go here hold on yeah now i should be
able to go no i still can't go back okay
hold on give me a second
maybe you should call those camera folks
and see oh yeah i know were they were
they local to the area or were they did
they come in out of town or what was the
deal uh
they are local you know that's why you
know oh they're loco all right yeah oh
you mean local yeah local yeah okay i
got you i got you okay so here we go
this is the mario this is the best that
my editor friend could do
and believe me
i appreciate it and you know just for
him trying how are you doing but he's
you know but again he's telling me john
this is you know this is unfixable
but i'll play it
but i'll play it for you anyway just for
posterity so people believe that i
actually attempted it you know what i
mean
so here we go
now again i preface it
you know it's not funny it's not fun
so here we go oh this looks much better
already yeah yeah yeah all right here we
go
[Music]
oh that's not so bad he just punched in
on the road on the rotation all right
that's better
uh
so
now keep in mind
that the audio is horrendous
you can barely hear
can you even hear my question
right now or on the video because on the
video you can hear yeah it's slightly
because i can hear it's competing with
the voices that are on the sidewalk
that's what i mean
right well no i know and you know okay
so so did they did they not because
because i i i tried to come in to to get
the story of the camera did they not
have another camera did they only have
the cell phones or something oh they've
had a camera but the guy's battery went
dead
he you know he didn't everything before
he started before he started yeah he did
one shoot of an open for me and he said
oh wait oh you know my battery's dead
i'm like
this sounds like a josh holly problem
you know what you must have another one
he doesn't have another one
so then i wait until this girl comes she
brings one but it's the wrong size
oh so she bought one and brought it and
then yeah yeah yeah and then she can
return it
that's what i see she's a nice woman
you know a really kind woman i'm not you
know i'm not you know but so now let's
play so mario's gonna explain why he's
at a republican club let's hear it
okay so here is his response to my
question okay
i gotta i gotta figure out how to add
this back oh oh here it is all right
here we go here's his response to how
can a man of color be at the republican
the capitol hill club all right here we
go
oh absolutely
um
so that was my little joke thing you
know you know yeah yeah yeah you know
are you happy that elon must put cocaine
back in coca-cola yeah i can't wait
i'm stoked for that
i can't wait to be on coca-cola with
cocaine and tweeting uh all at the same
time yeah that's going to be fantastic
even though he's not going to own
twitter or don jr is going to have a
hell of a time that's right that's right
it could be fun so that's like the like
you know because i didn't have you know
you know i didn't have a joke at the
time so i'm like all right let me just
you know
you know you know i'll run with
something because i didn't expect him to
be there you know and he's not a right
winger
apparently like you hear his excuse he's
saying i gotta try and get support for
the art from these nut nicks apparently
you know you know john the the best part
was that final part where you ask him
about
the uh the cocaine and coca-cola you
should just cut just that part and put
that on the internet that that that's
the best part because it the look on his
face when he's like wha what cocaine and
coca-cola like he's he's really he's
really intrigued by what you just said
no i know i know it's i can okay so now
here's here's my first question okay
hold on hold on what the hell all right
all right
you're not gonna believe this guys
so
hold on here is
the best i could do
with with the side clip this is this is
the best i could do
with the side clip of this interview
here okay so hold on
i don't know hold on let me find it here
hold on now i'm having a problem even
getting it
don't don't show us any of your private
videos john this is we just want to see
the ones from dc yeah i know i don't
know why
[Laughter]
okay so hold on it should be okay do you
see that
no we just we just see your youtube
channel yeah we just see the uh the one
yeah oh now we're back all right hold on
yeah you gotta share a different screen
there yeah i know just you know look
look trust me this is not easy right
here because i got all these different
horrible pieces of tape
the main question is did they get them
all edited to where
it was somewhat
edited
this way but wait i got up hold on guys
i get up
so
it's now
i don't know two o'clock
and the guy still hasn't sent me his fix
so i'm like all right you know
oh he he still hasn't sent the figure
you're still waiting on it yeah you're
still waiting no so i just said i said
you know what don't don't send me
anything don't bother
to take care you know i'm again where
did where did you find this guy
craigslist craigslist
john
john john that's where you find hookers
and blow is correct how would i know
tony and how did you know that
i'm not gabe told me gabe told me yeah
yeah you also you also find roommates
there you know
questions
oh here's the first congressman
i don't know if you're gonna hear the
interview i don't know you probably
can't it's shot in like iphone so i
don't know if you're gonna be even able
to make it out but i just want to prove
uh like to everybody that i did actually
i did actually get to some of these
congressmen i don't even know his name
maybe somebody in the chat will be able
to
find out i don't even know i just know
that he has nothing maybe we'll know him
we might be able to old round thing on
the lapel all right here we go
uh
is it an old dude
[Music]
i can't see it's not it's like perfectly
so his face is blown out
maybe maybe this isn't even a
congressman john i don't know what if it
was just a business man
congressman he's like yeah sure i'm
gonna go fight a lot whatever i'm i'm in
a suit i could be a guy
i can't believe you can't even
i can't believe that you can't even see
it you didn't see his face you can't see
i don't know who the hell that is how
are you supposed to know john yeah you
can't see the guy's face yeah the best
detectives
so the question was i forget what it was
it was something like uh
uh
when you're done with politics
do you plan on finally serving the
people
you know you know which is a funny
question yeah yeah
but you can't even say the damn thing
again maybe it might have been just some
patron in the restaurant that came with
a really good chef salad
and
he just was in a suit maybe not an
actual congressman no it was it was a
congressman how do you how do you know
for sure no i know for sure hold on you
know
no i definitely know for sure let me see
if i can play you without because i
don't know why because it didn't look
this bright on my phone so i don't know
if it's
you know was there something on my end i
could do i don't think no no well
no no
no no it's too exposed it's too exposed
okay so there's there's the first
goofball question
and it goes
you know so you can't even see it it's
just garbage
so you know this is what i'm dealing
with here i can't wait till we figure
out and this is this is all in one day
you were there you're just going around
asking questions different people
yeah that's two days now oh two days
okay so
you actually did you actually get
anywhere like uh
somewhere close to marjory taylor to
where you could ask no questions
none of them were there so now here's so
here's another congressman okay hold on
if i can let me see if i can find this
one okay
so here we go congressman number two
yeah yeah yeah
i mean this is how horrible i i am like
you know and again i'm not mentioning
you know i'm you know like i'm not gonna
okay so here we go uh
so here's another one
now this one was flipped so first i'll
play do you want to see a flip just for
the fun yeah sure why not you know i
think i think john i think john when
these people post on craigslist that
they'll film for you i don't think they
mean like a political question i think
they mean film other things like yeah
you know private type videos like
weddings
no no no no no no
after the wedding like after the wedding
yeah like after the wedding party even
you know like
you know when you're in the bedroom with
the second you know when you cross the
circle and all that kind of stuff yeah
like that kind of thing yeah i don't
know now here's another one
so i'll play this one now
okay this is how lame and bad this is
so hold on
uh
oh man
uh
this is my okay
all right here we go you ready for this
one
yeah
all right
well there you are i can see you
okay let's see what happens here okay
all right
i swear to god this is i'm telling you
this is the funniest part is just how
bad that's you standing there
oh oh that headed yeah
i think the funniest thing is how bad i
look in a suit
so here we go
i don't know the name of this
congressman either but maybe you guys do
well let's let's see if we can see him
sure okay
[Music]
do you think joe biden won the election
uh
well actually i won the election do i
have
this is what drives me crazy these guys
still can't admit
that joe biden won the election now wait
will you hear the cockamamie
delusion [ __ ] that comes out of this
congressman's
mouth if anyone can tell me who that guy
is wait till you hear he goes into mark
zuckerberg
kind of [ __ ] here tony gabe check check
out his excuse here okay
all right
all right here we go
i think there were security concerns and
some concerns about uh
[Music]
they say that all politicians are
lawyers which is your favor
[Laughter]
all right thank you
which is a funny question
yeah yeah it's true why not yeah there's
so many responses the response that he
has though he's like it reminds me of
like clinton when he was like well it
depends on what your definition is it's
like it depends on what your definition
of one is and it's like there is only
one definition of one so the question
was are they saying all politicians are
liars which is your favorite one you
know that's a funny question so okay but
it shot so badly like
it's not even like i want to play it you
know what i mean it's like i just did
john you just did
i did
i did because i did because you know
what i'm getting my money's worth
you definitely are like i said john i
think these people when they say they
film things for folks
i don't think they mean like
professionally
as in like it's gonna like they're like
oh it's gonna end up online all right
like it this whatever we're gonna film
is gonna end up online it's just a
different website than what you're
wanting to post it on maybe i'm just
saying that i think i think these people
that you hired typically
are filming people doing things that
aren't normally like interviewing
politicians they're doing different
types of interviews if you catch what
might drift there i get what you're
saying and i think you're right
no
i think maybe he shoots like you know
maybe he does
uh weddings or something you know what i
mean i don't know
maybe
but you think a guy with a wedding would
have a couple batteries though i mean
right that's the that's weddings
you only came in with one battery that
is the
with any electronic you're always like
i need at least one backup in case
anything goes wrong
right i mean i mean
on the
on the i am dressed like
some guy goes john you should have
dressed like a republican yeah i am i'm
in a suit like every one of these guys
what is wrong with you
right
so
now this is the this i think i think
they mean republican i think you mean
like a white hood i think that's yeah
it's true
like a white hood you should have this
is the last one that we got
actually the mario van peoples you know
you know you know
was the last one there's the stutter
hence the stuttering john podcast so now
i'm gonna play you the last one
and i'll you're probably not going to
hear the question so i'll tell you what
the question was and what he says
because i could hear him okay
all right my friends that's what you
should do just do a voiceover on the
whole thing yeah just dub it over and
just dub it over
you know i'm not putting the name out
i'm not trashing these people they were
nice people you know look i'm sure the
porn they normally shoot is perfect i'm
just you know this is not well that's
the whole style it's a pot
well i'm gonna say this is not their
forte how about that you know uh uh i
thought you were gonna say it's not
their fault and i was like no it is
their
[ __ ] forte for sure i thought i i
thought maybe foreplay for playing
i mean i don't know i don't know this is
not their forte i get it you know what i
mean
uh you know my mistake i'll play i'll
take the blame
like you said i got it on craigslist but
guess what i didn't know where else to
find a cameraman in dc i went through my
buddy doug goodstein i went through
another couple of people and i couldn't
find the crew and i was desperate so
john what did the craigslist ad say what
did it say what did the craze that's
what i want to know what the cr what did
the craigslist dad say oh do you want me
to tell you here yeah yeah yeah yes i
definitely want you to tell me okay
because maybe it's all my fault i want
to hear everyone see if there's any red
flags
yeah like okay let's sniff this out here
maybe it's all my fault in
you know in the listing uh let's see
uh let's see
so it says i'm stuttering john melendez
i plan on interviewing politicians in dc
next week and need a video audio person
to record these kamikaze style
interviews like i used to do on the
stern show
interviews must be able to be uploaded
immediately after completed
now i asked okay so you made the app oh
yeah yes
how many responses did you get
about i don't know seven or eight okay
and and this is the one you picked
because they seemed the most they said
that they knew what you know
i had to show you guys
[Applause]
you know and then i had to pull up on my
phone uh on my youtube uh video so he
could see them and it was the first time
he's ever seen them so i'm like oh
oh
oh my god well anyway here's my last one
okay let's see this one yeah yeah so
here's my last one and then we'll move
on to the republican party before i have
don winslow on so here we go
[Laughter]
he was receptive to that he was oh
did you hear the question yeah can you
repeat it yeah here we go
hi congressman how are you doing
a couple questions
dude why do you keep laughing and just
let me get a question
shut up i'm trying to listen hear the
question tony i can't help
i know but you always laugh over the
question
all right hold on now i gotta play it
again and again all right here we go
and now i now it's not playing this
model all right hold on you know do you
wanna can you can you read the can you
read out what the actual question was
like from the peace papers
shouldn't it be
so
so the question was
can i unmute now can i unmute now now
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay okay good start
2500 for not wearing a mask on the house
floor if anyone should be wearing a mask
shouldn't it be her
now wait did you say marjorie taylor
green to him or did you say marjorie
trailer no i said marjorie taylor green
but
i i don't even know right now but
that's a funny question he goes i don't
understand the question keep in mind
like i don't say news mess i said
nudes max because i don't want to get
sued so i say nudes max thanks to hal
sparks but
it's a funny question but he
you know he goes i don't even know how
to answer that and he walks away which
is a typical
how a typical stuttering john interview
ends them you know them just getting
pissed and walking away from from me
so there is he did he did his ears did
perk up yeah when you thought he heard
him he heard him
oh yeah oh no they're like this is my
this is my moment i'm finally going to
get on newsmax i'm going to be on trader
tv this is fantastic so now i'm just
going to put this out here
tony you're in what state
i'm in missouri
yeah that's too far from dc right
so
because i bet you i bet you you
i bet you you could film this like you
know i don't know one of those things
like this
yeah yeah tony tony will get on a
locomotive and you know what heather
yeah right
you can draw it on the posted thing and
just flip it yeah dude but yeah yeah
yeah we'll we'll do an anime you could
do an animation
oh
michael says there is a nudes max you
may get a lawsuit get it well
mine only has one mine has two exes
[Laughter]
yeah yeah yeah and mine smell uh spelt
you know no no oh did i say nudes max i
meant uh um
let's see uh you know help me out i i i
meant noodles
yeah like it's like as noodles yeah yeah
yeah noodles max yeah noodles man
so anyway
there it is so
that you know look at the end of the day
beautiful footage by the way john tony
at the end of the day
isn't it worth it just the how how
ridiculously bad it was
oh it it's it's it's horrible it's
absolutely horrible it's absolutely
horrible and i'm not sure i'm not sure
like what i would really want to know is
the other six people that responded to
your craigslist ad i want to know what
kind of equipment they would have shown
up with
oh no
i'll tell you
do you want to know yeah yeah
do i
do i oh yeah i want to know
yeah i'll definitely tell you hold on i
just got hold on
all right
this is what some of them said
all right um
uh
let's see
uh
uh
uh okay this one guy goes hello i'd love
to work on your up and coming project
all equipment is ready to go and so is
our team just look let me know exactly
what you need
uh
and then he then he gives me a whole
a cinematography whole like you know a
whole kind of resume here right so
here's another one
hold on uh
hold on let me find this thing again
i would i would i would have went with
that one
with the resume okay
okay let's see what else okay here's
another one uh
okay i am straight to being your video
guy and recording your news would love
to discuss this further your earliest
convenience looking back to hearing back
okay but there's one guy that actually
gives me actual
specifics okay so this one goes uh
let's see
uh i shoot up to 40k 60 and can roam
around i have a mobile lightweight
professional setup and i'm very used to
being in all sorts of environment
environments with little or no space he
sounds like he's good right yeah i mean
he shot anywhere from interviews to
porno probably yeah that's perfect
that's right so and everyone else just
called a camera horizon is that the guy
that you chose
no
no oh no no you wanna
yeah let's let's hear how the guy you
chose responded well i'm just i just say
his name he goes hi john
okay he goes hi john i'm a big fan of
the stern show
uh i'm a digital artist i'm from dc i uh
uh you know i don't know and uh i i
would love this opportunity
because this would be a hell of a
no and reference he goes let me know
what you need
uh from me and i'm your guy
there you go
so i i would have went with the one that
had some where's my credentials
so i'm your guy like now i'm like this
guy's confident he's a big stern joke
and he must know how my interviews go
this is my guy
never watch them though this was not my
guy
no i don't i don't i think i think the
first one and the second one
might have you might have tapped them
i mean were they wanting more money or
what was the situation
it was nothing like that you know like
they were content it was not like that i
got you you know and i think i think
next time you got to bring out your own
crew
you know well that's the thing you know
and next time yeah
uh
yeah i mean i mean i mean hell for that
kind of money hell i'll stand there and
hold the phone up where and sideways and
reel it away turn up your audio i
definitely don't do that
yes gabe i can [ __ ] up all kinds of
audio videos stuff i posted 150 bucks a
day for eight hours now granted
i knew i wasn't gonna do eight hours
because i can't i gotta tell you man i'm
getting old because as i'm standing in
front of that capitol hill club for two
and four
for two or three hours
my back is killing me and there's
nowhere to sit down and i'm just like
dude i'm getting too old for this kind
of you know because for jeffy chase i
stood for eight hours
uh you know uh uh to get him just like
a regina says i gambled then i lost true
yeah it happens yeah what happens man
you win something you sure you're going
back out there in this in the streets of
dc tomorrow is that where you're still
at no no i'm back in new york you know
oh
my friend said just consider this
a learning
experience and that's all i could do i
do know that you do it i i know they
hang out at the capitol hill club i bet
you if they were in session you know you
know
uh marjorie uh three toes i know she was
gonna be there i was going to ask her
a margaery since you you know you have
three names is that for the amount of
toes you have on each foot i mean you
know it was going to be like real
stuttering john you know gotcha like
funny questions but i wasn't afforded a
chance and keep in mind
when i would do the interviews on the
stern show
sometimes
50 of the time they didn't use the
interviews because like you know like
the guy knew me or
or he didn't say anything that was funny
but the one
constant
was
99.9 percent of the time the audio was
great and the video was great so
this is like i just i i'm overwhelmed
with disappointment yeah yeah well next
time next time go with the person that
has the experience in in the craigslist
response and also remember that
craigslist generally
not always i mean you can buy like a
used lawnmower on there but also like
hookers and blows with the uh
but but i definitely john i definitely
would go with the guy that had a little
bit of like hey here's my here's my
resume
maybe maybe he just said that to be like
oh if i say this then he'll hire me
right and then he said i'm your guy so i
said okay and he's confident i like that
yeah oh he was confident already yeah he
looked so comfortable he showed up with
one battery hey tony did that yeah you
could analyze it like any way you want
and and
you know like you know hindsight is 20
20 friends it is absolutely absolutely
like you know yeah i mean any way that
you look and you go oh yeah well you
should so i think i think i think john i
think though and in all seriousness or
unseriousness the way you look at it is
that the the fact that you're willing to
show that footage that's the best part
that's the best part because most people
just say i do the camera didn't work it
didn't work like me and gabe would just
say yeah we did oops yeah we'll get it
next time yep we'll get it next time you
know well well it's like my editor said
he's not my editor but he used to be my
editor and
you know a tonight show editor he said
john this is unfixable
just get rid of it
you know
i can't improve the audio it's it's a
mess
just
you know
don't even air it but you know
i add it just for the
hilarity of how bad it is right
the two things though that are that are
nuggets in this thing if you can
increase the volume at all i believe
that the the elon musk part where you
the joke that you said yeah are you
excited that he's bringing cocaine back
into coca-cola that's that's perfect
yeah and then and then when he when you
said the word nudes matt and mood's
nudes moods man
and he thought you said newsmax and he
was like huh
yeah i think i think those two things
could
could cause some internet stir i i
believe they could yeah i know you know
yeah
look up that's a good idea and maybe
i'll try that you know but
but i mean look you know at the end of
the day
you know i'm just like i was so pissed
off
i got home
my brother picked me up at the lirr you
know train station at uh
at you know like 7 30 you know i i just
went back no i like i forget like i
forget what time at seven i just went
back to his house drank some beer i
watched the yankees i was so pissed off
and then you know you know but like and
you know and then this morning
so angry and now that i played it
i don't know i'm kind of happy that i
had you guys here to play it
yeah exactly
because now at the end of the day it's
kind of funny how bad it is
oh it's it's hilarious it makes great
content for us to do commentary on for
sure right right absolutely absolutely i
know
like and i was even debating my i don't
know should i put it's so bad so i go no
i gotta play it because
cause look keep in mind
all my loyal people here and they're and
they're smart they're cool and they're
loyal
um
but and you know they would like super
chat me you know here's for the dc fund
so i figured you know what at least i
got to show that
they want to see the product
and let me tell you
my word i i said i was going to do it if
i got anything i'll do it now i didn't
upload it to patreon on youtube
immediately because it was so horrible
oh
well
i don't i don't know if you got punked
by these people or not but the the
result the result of today is perfect so
yeah yeah don't don't let me know
and self-deprecating humor is
some of the best
i'm glad it could be entertaining
oh i know a lot of people going i'm
crying i'm crying
i was entertained as [ __ ] today oh yeah
this is this is fantastic
i didn't know what to expect coming on
the show today no i'm pleasantly
surprised and glad yes
i know
well now i have to go drink a beer
[Laughter]
no i know i know and it's just like and
i just couldn't believe this is what i
was dealing with so
but you know
uh you got john you got don winslow
coming on the show is that what you said
yeah
you're going to talk okay don announced
uh uh
don if you're out there we're trying to
get you on we'd love to have you on yeah
we love it but uh
i noticed that he had like a it was he
retiring from writing is that is that
what i don't know i'm going to ask him
everything i can okay good good good
good
kelly
but john this will go down in history
i'm sure it will oh it'll live on the
internet forever now
ever and ever yeah yeah i don't even you
know but here the other the other thing
you could do is you could release the
videos and put uh you can put captions
on them so people know what's being said
well if you find the right editing
person yeah yeah yeah you can don't go
on craigslist and look for someone to
put captions because that's a great game
i will admit i'm technically
you know incompetent like i know
no sure
i know that i know that like look look
you know i don't make any false you know
uh you know i would never say i'm the
greatest technical guy
but so no i wouldn't even know how to
put closed captioning i see these guys
on instagram closed captioning on all
the you know i don't know how to do that
you know i wouldn't know the first thing
about it
so no have you heard have you heard of a
website called fiverr
fiverr.com
that that you need to go there
that's where you need to go john you
need to get there and next time
at least
i need to go shoot myself when the head
is where i need to go
next time just get a selfie stick
yes i mean for 150 bucks you can get a
hell of a selfie or uh or get a little
lapel mic with the with the selfie stick
and hold the hold the [ __ ] stick
while you're asking the questions
yeah could you imagine could you imagine
me going back to the stern show and this
being the footage and this is how it was
shut up
would have went
ballistic
he would have went crazy he wouldn't
give me that camera guy get him in here
right now he oh forget it he would have
taught that guy an [ __ ] and you know
but i don't want to do that because you
know the guy's a nice guy the girl is a
really sweet person i'm not going to try
i don't want to put the name out there
but you know it was really real he
wanted the reference johnny i hope i
hope he's watching because he's not one
now he didn't want to i don't think he
would you know i don't even care i
haven't lied about anything everything
i've said is exactly entirely true and
guess what i paid him so i'm in it clear
that's right that's right
but i i don't i don't know if i honestly
that just for me i don't know if i would
have paid him but you might be a better
man i need that i just
like you know i don't need him yeah
that's my mom that's what i said you
should have paid him you know that's
what everybody said don't pay him but
well hey hey here's the thing john
here's the thing is i think with this
show right here and the commentary that
we did on the footage you got your 150
bucks worth oh yeah totally yeah but how
about the other thousand with
the amtrak
the li double law the hotel
john life is about experience yeah john
what is about experience yeah look at
the experience that you yeah is the
experience greater than what you paid
yeah they probably
probably you know what i don't know
you know what the one to
here's what i learned today
i learned don't ever hire anyone from
craigslist thank you i'm just telling
you i've been saying i mean unless again
it's not a bad place you know i i don't
know personally gabe said this about you
know if you're gonna get uh blob or
hookers or look i think there's well you
might actually use apps for that
nowadays i don't i don't know i don't
know next time i'm bringing someone from
new york and and we're hopping in the
car
phone square yep and trying to yeah i
don't know
we're good yeah
just
ask them john before before you start
if they do bring a cell phone or just
say do you do the tick tock thing or do
you do the youtube thing and if they i'm
telling you they know how to do a tick
tock video you're in gold oh yeah yeah
they're you're
[Music]
so please plug anything that you want
tony gabe thank you so much because you
made the show just for last just for
seeing how bad this was i i i apologize
for laughing over all the lines
it probably made it funnier it was that
hilarious it was that hilarious uh guys
go watch our show it's every single
weekday monday through friday noon
eastern 11 center on youtube twitter
twitch two hours every single day it's
on youtube twitter twitch you can find
us at tonymichaelspod
on just type in the tony michaels
podcast or you can go to the midas touch
facebook page we also broadcast there
because we are proud partner midas dutch
just follow us me and gabe on
on the tweety tweets um i i'm at the
tony michaels and gabe what are you what
are you over there on the tweety tweets
i'm uh i am gabe sanchez thank you john
for having us
what kind of hispanic are you
uh i'm i'm mexican in spanish i'm puerto
rican oh nice yeah
all right man and danish sorry mom
uh
all right guys i'll see you man thank
you thank you we'll talk to you soon
we'll talk to you soon all right all
right take care all right the grace uh
gabe sanchez
tony michaels and uh now i'm waiting for
uh don winslow a legendary man so first
let me just say our partners at
betonline.ag continue to be the number
one source for all your better needs and
sports info find all of the latest
sports developments including updated
odds on the playoffs fights and even
next season's futures and don't forget
that baseball is back and the start of
the major league baseball season is
finally here bet online.ag is your
continued source for all your sports
wagering needs including live betting
and your favorite vegas casino and poker
games it's super easy to get started so
head to the website today or use your
mobile device to join and use our promo
code clns50
at clns50 to receive your 50 welcome
bonus on your first deposit but online
that ag where the game starts
okay
and uh
alrighty now we're just waiting
while we wait
let's all watch something else
that's even more bizarre than what we
just experienced
so here we go
uh all right let me just play this for
you guys
while we wait for the great don winslow
uh
uh
you know uh let's see uh
let's see
oh
i love my buddy
michael popock
all right let's see
it was a great time hanging out with him
okay uh so marjorie trailer green
tweeted out
if you are defending pedophile priests
and those who protect them groomer
teachers and disney lgbtq
propaganda drag queen story
time
saying it's not satan convincing women
to abort their unplanned child and that
children can be mutilated to change
their gender you're wrong
okay
this woman has lost the plot so let me
play you this
and and i can't believe this actually
so here we go
uh
well i hope
thank you yvonne i gave you a good laugh
yeah all these the joke was entirely on
me but i'll take it
all right here is
marjorie three toes
marjorie three toes on her
margaritas on on satan
oh it's whispered softly
it's whispered softly and gently into
your ears and into your soul
and he tells you it's okay and he says
it's just just this one thing
you're just gonna get it done get it
over with it and then he tells you a
promise
he promises you
all these dreams that that you have in
your heart
and that's how satan sells a sin and
that's how he sells abortion and he
tells a woman
that
all you do is you're just going to go to
this clinic just going to get it over
with you know and then you're going to
that guy he's going to stay with you
that that boyfriend or the guy whoever
he is he's going to marry you sleep you
off your feet
it's whispered softly and gently into
your ear
what a lunatic so what she's saying
people
is that satan
whispers into a woman's ear
telling them to have an abortion
okay
now
i don't know you tell me
if that person's out of a mind or not
now without further ado
let me bring on
don winslow
he's an american author best known for
his award-winning international
internationally best-selling crime
novels including savages the force in
the cartel trilogy
he has gained on notoriety for producing
a series of a series of videos critical
of donald trump in support of various
progressive causes and political
candidates
uh made with help from such public
figures as bruce springsteen and jeff
daniels winslow's uh videos have been
viewed by over
250 million people ladies and gentlemen
author of city on fire don winslow
ladies and gentlemen
hey how are you john nice to be back
john
i'm so happy that you're back i i i i
okay
i'm hearing myself back
i don't know what to tell you john i
mean we're in the room in dallas um okay
it's all right it's okay yeah yeah so
so tell everybody you know that now this
is the best seller now a city on fire
isn't it yeah yeah it's doing great yeah
that's got to feel incredible done i
mean like to have a best-selling book i
mean i think every every one of your
books on bestsellers
well not at first but lately last yeah
last 10 years or so yeah yeah yeah it
feels great
well uh
uh before you tell everybody what the
book's about you know i actually have
the you know
but
um tell everybody how persistent i am
and trying to get you to come on the
show very persistent john you're very
persistent and it hasn't been you know
hasn't been that i haven't wanted to you
know because i had a great conversation
with you last time i think the last time
we talked was shortly before the
presidential election yeah wasn't it
like the day before or two days yeah or
something yeah yeah we had a very tense
conversation because both of us were
uptight we were anxious right
yeah well it hasn't been from what you
know not wanting to come it's just you
know busy times so yeah no no i just
because people don't understand how how
actually because you know it's a lot of
work to book guests and and and i have
to be persistent else i'm not going to
get anybody you know what i mean it's
true in all walks of life isn't it you
know
yeah it is and but i really appreciate
that i love your films
you know you've been doing the films i
believe before the lincoln project and
the midas touch brothers i think that's
true i think that's true yeah yeah we've
been at it a while you know
uh yeah my my friend my partner
you know co-conspirator shane salerno
and i do the films i do the twitter you
know and so yeah i think it's worked out
well and i think we've made an impact
yeah and what
got you like
i'm just curious i i probably asked you
last time but it's been a while but what
got you
into doing these films is it because of
trump is that what just made you
yeah yeah absolutely absolutely look
look man you know without getting
sententious about it i love this country
i love this country you know and and i
think we're at a moment here in our
democracy where we could lose it
you know i felt that certainly in 2020
you and i talked about this at some
length uh and we're not out of the woods
yet
and so uh yeah we we started doing this
and and tend to continue i just want to
show you joanie i love your books
uh mr winslow thank you for all you do
everyone's giving you a lot of love i'm
sure they're all good i'm sure everyone
will be
buying your books that's a promise
because
uh here's another one
don winslow is amazing you know
so in the chats trust me everybody's you
know you know everybody's giving you
props please tell us what city on fire
is about before we talk about
the craziness that's going on right now
oh sure yeah look city on fire uh it's
my latest book it's the first of a
trilogy so there'll be two more coming
out in a year and a year uh it's the
first book i've ever set at home in my
hometown in rhode island i was born a
staten island but raised in rhode island
uh and it's about a guy named danny ryan
who starts off life as a longshoreman
and a fisherman working guy
marries into the family of the ruling
irish mob boss marries his daughter and
and because of that is dragged into a
mob war between the irish and the
italians in new england
this this sounds to me don like it's
going to be a movie
it is going to be a movie you know
[Laughter]
sony bought it when it was still in
manuscript form bought all three books
wow
congratulations thank you thank you very
much
awesome
thank you thanks a lot
whoa i mean i'm so happy for you so so
are you going to write the screenplay
no no no no no they'll get someone much
better than me to do that you know uh
yeah and have they told you like giving
you an idea of who they're going to try
and get to directly because i see
scorsese in the future who knows who
knows man i'm not gonna you know toss
names around but we'll see we'll see
so don
you know
even though trump is not president
anymore
he still
trumpism is still alive and well just
for instance i just played some
interviews you know that i did in dc i
was in dc yesterday
and i asked the congressman
do you do you think joe biden won this
election
and they won't admit it he would not
admit it he goes into some
bs about
about facebook and mark zuckerberg and
the ballots being counted i mean
what is going on
well it's cloud cuckoo land you know but
what it really what it really boils down
to is just sheer cowardness
cowardness and this craven attitude
where they feel they need to bow down to
this god you know
of of donald trump and his coterie of
imitators
um
let's let's tell the truth shall we joe
biden won by over seven million votes
yeah period endo story but you have to
realize you're talking to people
who talk about a child sex trafficking
ring
run out of a pizza place
out of its basement
in a place that has no basement
well
how do you talk to people like that
well that's the crazy part about it
because donald trump was at another
rally
which i can't believe people go to this
thing yeah well and and and you know
he's still
spewing the lie i mean
i mean do you think he's going to run
again then oh i do i definitely do yeah
i think he's going to run again i think
if he wants the nomination it's his
and uh we're going to have to fight him
again and we're going to have to beat
him again
here's the problem here's the real issue
though okay
16 months after
the insurrection
okay 16 months after we saw donald trump
heard donald trump trying for instance
to suborn votes in in georgia
after the insurrection what have been
the consequences john
well
zero zero
zero
so not a single republican involved in
that mess has been subpoenaed
not one
and now we're issuing polite invitations
please come talk to us
why aren't we issuing subpoenas
why aren't we putting these people under
oath why won't we make them appear in
front of congress
under penalty of perjury
and then if they you know they have a
constitutional right to take the fifth
let them take the fifth and let the
whole world see it
yeah yeah i know and you see jamie
raskin is going crazy because he's going
you know come on man you know like he
doesn't like he's like this is
everyone's really kind of getting mad
are you as frustrated as i am with um
garland at this point well sure look i
mean
there have been no consequences yeah and
it's not just 16 months
five years ago
right
we heard this man
went on national television and said
i fired james comey in order to shut
down the russia investigation
yeah that's a crime that's been five
years three and a half years ago all
right mueller came out and said there
are cases that are probably prosecutable
you know the cases have been built up
they're ready to go
what's happened nada
did you ever see the movie don uh don't
look up
no oh don you gotta see it dude it's
exactly what
it's exactly what is going on right now
i mean it's it's just
it's about a comment that's going to hit
the earth and and the republican uh
response to it and it's
it's just like
what's going on with climate change it's
what has happened with covid yeah it's
it's what happened with the masks
it's what happened with the best wars it
is everything that's going on right now
and don like you know you you know
you've been around i've been around i've
never ever seen
something like this ever in our history
no no you know i'm old enough to
remember watergate right yeah i was very
young
to remember watergate right
now what was watergate watergate was a
break in to get information a cheap
little burglary and it brought down the
president and people went to prison
when you compare what happened with
watergate with what happened in and
around january 6th you're comparing a
misdemeanor to a felony murder
yeah
yes
because they tried to kill the republic
and let's let's not forget that five
people died as a result of january 6th
and so i think it's incumbent on us to
keep reminding people what actually
happened
who was responsible because if we don't
it's not just a matter of retribution
right i don't believe donald trump's
going to spend a day behind bars i hope
i'm wrong i hope i'm wrong but i think
i'm right it's not just a matter of
retribution it's a matter of what's to
stop it from happening again
yeah
let's say trump runs which i think he
will
and let's say we beat him again which i
pray to god we will and i think we will
but we have to fight very hard to do it
what's to stop them from saying the big
lie all over again yeah and launching
the same kind of attacks and what
happens if it's a republican-controlled
house that's enthrall to donald trump
yep
and i know what's the craziest thing don
is
he's not a bright guy you know like he
says that we
you know took over the airports in the
revolutionary war you know and
they're following this false prop
this false prophet
he's not that he's he's not smart yeah
he's bragging about a cognitive death
but that's part of the problem
i think that people like particularly in
complicated difficult anxious times
which these past few years have been
people like simple answers to
complicated questions
right whether those answers are true or
false so the trumps of the world they're
basically carnival barkers but they give
simple answers to complicated questions
people seize onto them and hold on to
them
so why did we lose well the election was
stolen
where's the evidence there is no
evidence
right
but with conspirators conspiracy
theorists the absence of evidence is
evidence
it's what i call the see how good they
hide thing you remember you know with
your kids right and they say there's a
ghost in the closet i can't get to sleep
because there's a ghost in the closet so
you go in and you open up the closet
right see there's no ghost oh the ghost
is under the bed uh okay let's look
under the bed i don't see a ghost oh the
ghost is behind the curtain oh i look
behind the curtain there's no ghost and
the kid's response is always see how
good they hide
you know
and so the more you you try to say well
but where's your evidence that the
election was stolen well it's such a
deep conspiracy
you know it's been
well hidden
i don't know
wow i mean it's it's you know it is it
is is crazy and let me tell you
something don
i was at the um capitol hill club in dc
you know that's yeah
and um
there were capitol hill police going in
there to hang out with everyone and have
lunch
you know and then come out
don
i can't understand when the republicans
um
you know uh uh uh incited an
insurrection
and it killed the five capital
hill police i mean
they're going in there and hanging out
with these people
can you explain that to me no i can't
explain it to you i can't there's so
much john that you know we can't explain
but all we can do
is try to tell the truth
in plain simple and sometimes tough
language
right
and and do it over and over and over
again
and um
what do you make
of joe biden's job right now
i think joe biden's doing a good job
i think he's doing a good job i think we
need to do a better job of getting that
message out yep
you know look i mean this is a
fundamentally decent man following in
the footsteps of a fundamentally
indecent man yep right he had to come in
after
four years of total chaos
lies
you know distortion doesn't even even
you know reach it right
um
and
in the middle of a pandemic
and by the way the buying administration
did a fantastic job yep
right did you see how things changed
yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's like we can yeah you
know everyone's go to stadiums no one's
wearing masks anymore i mean beans got
into people's arms boom boom boom boom
boom like that right and then you have
ukraine
right
you know so yeah we have inflation
that's a problem uh i think there was
you know a bad growth report recently
unemployment's at an all-time low yeah
you know so i think biden's doing a
basically good job but i i would like
the party i'd like the democratic party
to be stronger
on its messaging
yes no and every guest i've had here you
know has been saying that i've had
congressmen
on and they say the same thing we got to
do better at our messages and we have to
fight back i mean that um that state
senator you know who was accused of
grooming children and names going out in
my head i'm sorry mcmahon
you know
that was incredibly bracing for her to
stand up and say you're liars you're
bullies oh yes i remember yeah senator
mcmorrow yes yes uh and we need more of
that you know and and
listen we don't and we don't need the
kind of polite language you know
that's not exactly true the actual case
is that we say you're a liar
that's a lie
yep
bam
you know
uh kate friedman please ask donna to
talk about his new political activities
yet
are you still doing the uh are you still
doing the films well in fact john i i
made an announcement i think this has
been a few days now on twitter that i'm
retiring uh from writing
in order to be more active politically
oh okay
okay so the answer to your your viewer
is yes
okay that's actually you know i'm sorry
that you're retiring from being a writer
but i'm happy that you're doing the
films that you do because we need more
and more and more
of this kind because
i you know
you know i believe you we really have to
fight and try and and try and
get uh get the message down i mean like
look look just here look
this is
um
you know this is a tweet today from uh
uh
uh tristan snow i remember that the ku
klux klan also persecuted catholics as
well as blacks and jews marjorie taylor
green's anti-catholic uh remarks this
week saying satan controls the church
are the continuation of a long line of
bigotry no one in the republican party
condemned her
now that's going on right now don kevin
mccarthy has not
ever
you know done anything to her even after
she heckled the president at the state
of the union yeah no it's terrible but
listen
we cannot expect decent behavior from
the republican party anymore and i've
said this before after they refused to
impeach trump after he incited
a coup tried to you know stage a coup to
overthrow the democratic government of
the united states the republican party
refused to impeach him
i will never vote for another republican
for any office for any reason for as
long as i live
if abraham lincoln came back tomorrow
and rang for dog catcher in my town on
the republican ticket i'm voting for the
other guy
yes and that's completely disgraced
itself well i'm sure there's some uh gqp
members who think he might be coming
back
did you see them gathering in dallas
waiting for jfk junior to come back
you know i mean i'm in dallas right now
as a matter of fact and i i just drove
through dealey plaza what a strange
kind of feeling that is yeah yeah i've
been there i've been on the grassy knoll
it's yeah it's very it's creepy it's sad
yeah yeah but yeah i
you know you know i'm
yeah i think everything
that you're saying is true i mean it's
just and now
with the with ron desantis and greg
abbott
doing this don't say gay bill
and doing the
they're banning abortion now in oklahoma
they just banned abortion yeah or it was
tennessee i mean
oklahoma yeah
how would any woman
vote
for a republican at this point don a lot
of them do look a lot of them do and we
are in in the so-called culture war but
what we need to remember okay
is that we won the election
yeah please
we won
yes
right
and
and when we talk about these culture war
issues
we we often see
the the idea of patriotism and the idea
of morality to the right
they have claimed that right you're
walking down the street and a truck
comes the pickup truck comes by and it's
got the american flag hanging out the
back end you think what it's a right
winger yes
right you're exactly right yeah but john
that flag belongs as much to me and you
as it does to him yep right the ideas of
patriotism and morality belong just as
much to us
as it does to them and what we need to
be doing is speak louder speak firmly
and speak more bravely
about what our values are
yeah and
the scary thing is republican if anyone
has been anti-american had spit in the
republican party trying to over
illegally overturn an election hey john
do you remember the footage right yes
these people claiming to be patriots
with a flag with trump's face emblazoned
in the middle of the flag
that's not
running
patriotism
confederate flag
through the capitol for the first time
in history the first time in history
right and listen i can take you to the
exact place where my great great great
grandfather was killed in the civil war
fighting to end slavery and fighting to
keep this country got taken to the exact
spot yeah yeah
watching that flag go through that
capitol building i was enraged but let's
just calm down and say that's not
patriotism
to attack
catholics
not patriotic
any minority anybody for their religion
obviously it's not what this country is
about but we need to do a better job of
standing up bravely
and saying so
yeah it is interesting to say that
because like and the other fall back
like i i had a friend
you know who picked me up from the
airport and yeah you know and and we
never talked politics because because i
know that he's probably you know he's a
drummer but he goes look you know
all politicians lie i think they're all
a bunch of liars that's see that's like
the fallback position well yeah trump
lies but every everybody lies come on
don donald trump lied more than any
president we've ever had in history yeah
it was like what 28 000 lies or
something some amazing number yeah look
there's lies and there's lies right yeah
uh but this guy lied about everything
from the beginning from the birther
controversy he lied about you know
president obama
not being born here to the very end
lying about whether he won the election
or not he lied
constantly
i know and what do you think is going to
happen in the midterms like normally
you know you know these parties
yeah
i mean historically the party in power
loses in the midterms but let's see i'm
saying let's not seed anything the
likelihood is yes but let's not seed
anything
cause what are you supposed to do johnny
are you supposed to just throw your
hands up and give up are you supposed to
lay down on the couch in a fetal
position
the end of the world hell no
yeah yeah over 30 000 lies uh someone
just wasn't 30 000 okay yeah i must have
missed the last two days of his
presidency
and he continues to lie and it just and
and it's never ending and
don i kid you not there was a woman i
played on my show i think on thursday
who was convinced that joe biden
is dead and that jim carrey and james
woods is wearing biden masks yeah yeah
but you know look you can't talk to
those people right
there's not enough aluminum hats in the
world you cannot talk to those people
but there are people
in swing states who you you really can
talk to
you know i live in an area
uh that's 76 republican
where do you live well it's an old ranch
outside of san diego i live there half
the year in rhode island half the year
so
most of my neighbors are not very close
right it's an old ranch are are
republicans yeah you know you can have
conversations
you can have conversation
conversation about gun control you know
a little cowboy across the fence
and he said i'm against gun control i
said well let me ask you this
do you think you should have the right
to own a shoulder-fired missile launcher
with a nuclear-tipped missile
he said of course not i said well you
already believe in gun control now let's
just see where we draw the line yeah
that's great i love that you know uh i
had another guy guy pulled up a pickup
truck behind me i'm walking out on the
highway by our house and i feel the
pickup truck moving behind me and
slowing down right someone yells out
from the pickup truck are you don
winslow
and i said yeah he said i don't like
what you write on twitter
so i walked over there
you know because he'd stop the car yeah
i leaned into his window and i said what
is it you don't like well you go after
people like me
you know i said well no
if if you're a person who invaded the
capitol yeah i think you should be
arrested and investigate he said well
we've never been heard
and i said what do you mean you had 61
lawsuits and all of them lost
yeah
what and what did he say what more here
well i'll bottle you know but then you
know then
we go we sort of got talking about the
weather and kids and
you know and try to defuse the situation
but you know you you can have
conversations but there's some people
you cannot have conversations with and
you just you know wasting your time if
some lady thinks that you know jim
carrey's playing joe biden you know
uh
olga martinez says john ask about the
martial law thing i did i'm not really
as you're talking about the um
audrey charlotte green thing i don't
know yeah there's been so much about
that
yeah no but it is
you know you're exactly right that's a
great way to try and
you know get the gun control thing down
because that's an import i just had the
congressman from illinois uh sean caston
on yeah you know and he's all about the
gun control thing and you know
it is kind of amazing that they don't
what i don't understand don is that
these a lot of these
are republican
um congressmen a lot of these
republicans have children
yeah
aren't they worried about their children
you know going to school
they're more worried about the nra but
another way to have that conversation is
to talk about cop killings
right yeah 90 percent of the time a
police officer is killed it's he's
killed with a gun
so
there are ways to sort of enter this
conversation
you know
uh but
you know again i think we we just have
to
stick to our principles stick to our
values not be embarrassed about them not
back up
you know if if we want to say that that
a gay person an lbgt person has every
right that anybody else has then we need
to say it loudly and strongly and not
back up
yes you know because it's our country
too
sorry conservative white male it doesn't
just belong to you
and by the way it never did
yep and you know what it's it's so it's
so crazy you just said that because
uh someone just wrote hey
you know i want my flag back you know
because like you said you know it
the american flag is the american flag
it's all of us but they they have taken
ownership of that flag they have and we
should take it back
yeah we should take it back you know
because what are patriotic values
you know
the guys standing there defending the
capital those are the patriots in that
that struggle
yes no i know and don i you know you
know i i you know i think i promised
your people i i would only have you on
yeah
yeah i've got a yes
but
please go ahead and plug your book again
and and and
again congratulations on
on having a three three picture deal
with sony that's awesome
pretty cool i'm pretty happy about it
the book city on fire uh yeah it's on
sale everywhere and i hope you all like
it
well don thank you so much and i know i
probably won't get you on again for
another eight months to a year but
please come back again i love talking to
you things are calming down give me a
call back we'll get it there
all right don thanks again thank you
john thanks for having me man all right
i'll see you the great don winslow and
his book cd city on fire that you can
get right now and go get it uh to
criminal empires together control all of
new england until a beautiful woman
comes between the irish and the italians
launching a war that will see them kill
each other destroy an alliance and set a
city on fire danny ryan yearns for a
more legit life and a place in the sun
go by city on fire by the great don
winslow thanks john all right brother
soon man okay brother bye-bye all right
i'll see you
all right don winslow well this has been
an entertaining show to say the least
uh you know i want to thank my guests uh
tony michaels and gabe uh
wait what was gabe's last thing no i'm
just blanking on it for a second is it
sanchez
it was uh
let's see gabe sanchez yes it was
my memory is impeccable
um
anyway uh it was a great show today no
beer in the balcony day because i had to
do the show later cause don could only
do the show today at five
and so that's why i started late
and uh so no i'll probably do one
tomorrow if i can get a guest and if not
i'll do two next week i've been
traveling like crazy as you know
from la to florida to new york
to dc back to new york and in a couple
of days i'll go back to la
and then do the whole thing over again
in may
so i'll be back in florida so i just
hope that you continue to donate
uh to my paypal i mean it you know it's
always appreciated continue to donate to
my venmo uh you know i mean like
everything helps
and uh and it and it's you know it's
awesome it was super chat saturday i
thank those that did super chat but it
was a very but i understand you know if
you know like if you don't have the
money it's
you know
you know inflation is at an all-time
high and unfortunately
people i have people
you know blame
joe biden i'm like
there's inflation
all over the globe no there's not
dummies they're a bunch of dummies
anyway i'll thank my moderators nikki b
and benny loco i'll also thank uh my
sponsor bet online.ag
and uh again i'll thank i'll thank my
guests tony michaels gabe sanchez and
the great don winslow
uh please buy his book city on fire and
i'll be back here again
not on tuesday i'm flying on tuesday
sorry folks so i'll be back uh
on thursday but we have
an incredible amount of guests coming up
with names that you're
that you know
and uh i don't have to say them now but
i have congressman coming on
and i have
uh you know just trust me you will be
very
happy
with the guests that i have uh
on the slate uh that'll be on in may and
june so uh
thanks again everybody
and uh i'll see you
maybe tomorrow on beer on the balcony
become a patreon member patreon.com
stutteringjohn also
you can become um
a youtube member
and um
let me
uh
again
go to the internet jackass
i-t-i-n-e-r-a-n-t jackass subscribe to
his podcast because he was nice enough
to flip the video
for me with his editing you know editing
program
um
nancy rose john have jim carry on so he
can tell the truth i will
and um there was something else i wanted
to say oh please
subscribe
to my channel the stuttering john
podcast channel
please subscribe
because i'm contemplating only allowing
the chats from people who are
subscribed it doesn't cost you anything
it's just a click hit the thumbs up
button and subscribe if you haven't
subscribed already please subscribe
because it builds up my numbers
and by building up my numbers i get more
respect from youtube so please
do that if you can alright everybody
i'll see you soon this is stuttering
john saying